Es ist wieder soweit, wir blicken auf den europäischen Fußball bei den Männern. Heute sind mit dabei die Ligen Premier League, Eredivisie, Ligue 1 und La Liga mit Nils Kern, mit Nils Kern, Uli Hebel, Daniel Zander und Jakob Haffke. Und jetzt geht's los. Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen. Ein fieser Bug hat uns die Hälfte dieses Intros vorenthalten. Euch nicht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, denn für euch hab ich's gefixt. Aber ich muss sagen, mir fehlt was. Aber was soll man tun? So ist die Technik manchmal. Hallo und herzlich willkommen hier im Rasenfunk. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost und ich freue mich sehr, hier wieder meine Runde begrüßen zu dürfen in einer Champions League Woche. Und Daniel Zander hat schon gesagt, als Fan des niederländischen Fußballs verfolgt man das gerade nicht so gern. Daniel, wo drückt der Schuh? Überall leider.
Da wird es harte Verhandlungen gegeben haben, weil Chelsea ja schon wusste, Straßburg muss kaufen, weil sie haben ja schon drei von uns geliehen. Da haben die den Preis aber richtig nach oben getrieben. Also es ist einfach nur zu hassen. Ich sage es, wie es ist und ich möchte einmal diesen Punkt hier gemacht haben, weil der in der Debatte eine viel zu geringe Rolle spielt. Es laufen jetzt gerade wieder Leute rum aus aktuellem Anlass und erzählen, sobald die Bundesliga sich für Investoren öffne, dann könne man endlich mit Premier League auf Augenhöhe und man könnte dann wie Manchester United und der HSV, Riesenverein und Schalke usw. usf. Überlegt mal ganz kurz, was ist denn das wahrscheinlichere Szenario? Ist das wahrscheinlichere Szenario, dass jemand kommt und sagt, das hier ist der eine Verein, in den ich investiere, weil ich die Bundesliga so geil finde und hier stecke ich jetzt richtig, richtig viel Geld rein oder ist nicht das viel wahrscheinlichere Szenario, dass jemand sagt, ich habe schon fünf Vereine, geil, jetzt kann ich noch eine Bundesliga einhaben. Nachwuchs ist ja bei denen eh gar nicht so schlecht, aber weiter ist mein Premier League Verein die absolute Nummer eins und dann bist du nämlich dann bist du der HSV nur im Gewandetes von Racing Straßburg oder eben ein…
Titelvorschlag für die Folge, ey mega dieses Multi-Club-Ownership, weil ich hatte eben das Gegenbeispiel Girona, wie schnell man dann vermeintlich fallen gelassen wird vor zwei, drei Jahren, alles super, auch Top-Fußball gespielt und jetzt unser aktuell tabellenletzter mit wenig Hoffnung, dass das besser wird, aber ja also Racing Straßburg, nächstes Jahr Champions League und dann in drei Jahren auch irgendwie Abstiegskampf. Mal gucken.
Ja und das ist ja sowieso schon ein Problem, dass du das Gefühl hast, dass als Fan bist du der Einzige, der bleibt beim Verein. Alles andere wechselt durch. Spieler, Manager, Trainer und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist sowieso schon schwierig manchmal mit anzusehen, mit welcher Geschwindigkeit dadurch gewechselt wird und weil auch oft gar nicht mal so getan wird, als ob es jetzt wirklich um den Verein geht, sondern es geht halt um die Möglichkeit, dort Fußball zu spielen, was ein Stück weit legitim ist, aber als Fan kann dir das weh tun. Und das wird einfach so pervertiert durch Multi-Club-Ownership. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Und das kommt nach Deutschland. Wenn 50 plus 1 fällt, dann muss man sich gar keine Illusionen machen. Warum sollte es anders sein? Es gibt kein einziges logisches Argument. Deswegen wollte ich den Punkt hier nochmal machen. Ich beruhige mich jetzt und wir blicken nochmal auf die Ehre Divisi. Das macht vielleicht mehr Spaß, wobei ich gerade gar nicht genau weiß, ob dieses Segway funktioniert. Was macht denn Luis Holtby bei Breda? Macht er denn Spaß?
Er macht Spaß, aber ich will einmal, was die Bilder mal aufgreifen, weil ich weiß, wir haben leider ein Negativbeispiel, wenn man nach Bethesda Arnheim schaut.
Das stimmt.
Die ist, glaube ich, ein Multi-Club-Ownership, aber die haben auch verschiedene Investorengruppen gehabt und konstrukte. Und aktuell sind sie in der zweiten Liga mit minus fünf Punkten tabellenletzter. Das sagt auch schon viel über Punktabzug und alles. Sie waren auch sehr, sehr kurz davor, überhaupt die Profil-Gizenz entzogen zu bekommen. Und erst bei einer Berufung, die wurde jetzt erstmal Schachtel geben, dürfen sie jetzt auch erstmal spielen. Also das auch da ist ein weiteres Negativbeispiel für Investoren, die auch schnell keine Lust mehr auf ihr Spielzeug haben. Und dann hast du einen Club mit einer sehr reichheitlichen Geschichte, auch mit vielen Lines und Chelsea. Ich weiß, der Anderen war da auch immer sehr eifrig dran. Und die sind jetzt in der zweiten Liga mit minus fünf Punkten. Und wie es da jetzt wirklich bei dir geht, ist da auch noch offen. Aber wenn wir jetzt zum spaßigen Teil kommen, dann kommen wir zu der Lügis Holpik-Nachtphase. Ich glaube, ich habe in einem Interview gelesen, der war so ein bisschen auf das Geld in Saudi-Arabien aus, im Nahen Osten. Und dann kam wohl der Anruf von Breda, und der hat dann sofort zugesagt. Und ist da jetzt auch relativ schnell zum Fan-Liebling aufgestiegen. Was auch damit zu tun hat, dass er am zweiten Spieltag gebetiert hat und gleich das 1-0 dann gegen Sittard geschossen hat. Das Spiel haben sie am 2. gewonnen. Also das war ein perfekter Einstieg. Und er passt so ein bisschen zu dieser neuen Philosophie, die Breda jetzt sich angeeignet hat. Vergangene Saison hatten sie einen sehr mutigen, sehr offensiven Ansatz gewählt und versucht auch mit schnellem Kurzpass-Spiel da voranzukommen, was auch eigentlich gut funktioniert hat. Und jetzt versuchen sie so ein bisschen einen rustikaleren Ansatz, also mehr über Zweikämpfe zu kommen, mehr über Körperbetonteil. Und die Rolle füllt Holt B auf die Doppel-Sechs halt auch einfach hervorragend aus. Und das passt sehr gut. Breda ist jetzt noch mal nicht so erfolgreich, sie ist auf 15, haben aber auch schon zweimal gewonnen und haben jetzt auch gegen Ajax nur 2 zu 1 verloren zuletzt, was auch respektabel ist, weil sie sich ein bisschen so auf diese Kompaktheit konzentrieren und das eigentlich auch gut machen. Und Holt B hat auch schon gleich eine eigene Fan-Nummer bekommen. Also auf diese Melodie von Mackerkontakt haben sie da auch irgendwas gleich wieder gesungen. Und was auch immer interessant ist, sind ja die Ätymologie der Namen, die Herkunft der Namen, der Vereinsnamen. Und NAC Breda heißt, das N steht für Neut-Op-Reven-Allt-Teil-Dorsetten, also niemals aufgeben und immer weitermachen. Und das passt ja eigentlich gut zu Holt B, ist mir so aufgefallen, so ein bisschen sinnbildlich. Unser Vorständigkeit halber, das A steht für andere Namen der Vermarkt, der Nütter, der Ruhr und Spanning. Also angenehm durch Unterhaltung und Mehr davon bitte. witzig für Entspannung. Und das ist eine Fusion aus diesen zwei Vereinen. Das waren die Leiter dieser beiden Vereine. Und das C ist Kombinazi, also Kombination. Das heißt, der vollständige Name von NAC Breda wäre dann nicht obrevent, allzeit dorsetten. Andere Namen der Vermarkt, der Nütter, der Ruhr und Spanning. Kombinazi Breda. Und das nur als Randnotiz. Und ja, Nils Hortby fast zum ersten Teil zu Niemals aufgeben. Eigentlich doch ziemlich gut. Und ist sofort angekommen, ist auch, was man so hört, bei der Mannschaft sehr beliebt und kann relativ, ist ein gutes Beispiel, wie man relativ schnell zu einer ganzen Identifikationsfigur werden kann. Ist nach sieben Spieltagen und davon nur sechs gespielt, ein Spiel relativ schnell, ist aber eigentlich schon so Faktor um Bord. Ich habe, ich kriege eine gute Chancen aus, dass sie dann auch mal dieser Mentalität dann auch drin bleiben in der Liga.
Ich habe nur noch eine Frage. In der Vereinshymne von NAC Breda wird da der Name komplett ausgesprochen und ist die Hymne direkt danach dann vorbei? Ist das der komplette Refrain?
Nein, es wäre möglich. Es wäre lauig möglich, aber das haben sie sicher doch nicht getraut. Aber es gibt, das könnte man auch mal irgendwie mehr beleuchten, es gibt da wirklich tolle Siebblüten von Vereinsnamen in den Niederlanden.
Ja, wir haben ja schon die Go Ahead Eagles hier rechtzeitig abgefeiert, bevor sie dann auch auf die nationalen Medien hier aufgesprungen sind. Okay, wir blicken noch einmal kurz nach Spanien. Auch hier geht es eher um einen Verein, der Probleme hat, Nils.
Ja, das sind jetzt nicht ganz so gravierende Probleme wie vielleicht beim FC Girona, auch wenn die Parallelen da sind. Real Sociedad hatte vor zwei Jahren Wahnsinn in der Champions League, damals noch mit Miquel Merino, Robbele Normand, da gab es dann auch eben zwei Leistungsträger, die sind weg, hatten dann letzte Saison schon Probleme in La Liga. Jetzt in diesem Sommer ist dann auch noch Soubih Mendy auch zu Arsene, top Transfer, kann man nur gratulieren. Nur merkt man das auch bei LAR Ealteste da aktuell, sogar drittletzter sind fünf Punkte aus sieben Spieltagen. Ich würde aber da sagen, da ist die Lage nicht ganz so prekär wie zum Beispiel Girona. Real Sociedad hatte zum Beispiel schon die beiden Duelle mit Basel, mit Real Madrid da null Punkte rausgeholt. Bei ihnen, bei den Basten ist so ein bisschen eher das Problem. Erst mal gab es jetzt auch den großen Wechsel im Sommer. Immanuel Alguacil nach sieben Jahren hat ja unter anderem die Copa gewonnen, hat selbst erkannt, dass der Zyklus ein bisschen vorbei ist, dass es was Neues braucht. Er kam damals aus der zweiten Mannschaft. Jetzt ist auch Sergio Francisco aus der zweiten Mannschaft hochgezogen worden. Er war damals sogar der Nachfolger von Xabi Alonso in der zweiten Mannschaft. Also die setzen viel auf Nachwuchs. Sie haben eine große Jugendakademie, holen viele Spiele raus. Da steckt schon viel Nachhaltigkeit und Zukunft auch drin. Nur ihr großes Problem ist so ein bisschen eher die Effektivität. Sie hatten ja jahrelang, waren auch gut verwöhnt. Da waren mal ein Alexander Isak da, ein Alexander Sirloot. Silver zum Beispiel hat nicht geklappt und auch andere Spieler. Und so haben sie jetzt aktuell mal XG-Werte zu nennen. Haben sie nur 7 Tore erzielt, aber laut XG in der Liga hätten sie eigentlich 11 Tore haben müssen. Nur Raio hat einen noch schlechteren Effektivitätsschnitt. Also, sie spielen sich schon ein paar Chancen aus. Da sind immer noch ein paar gute Kicker wie ein Oya Zabal, wie natürlich auch Take Kubo. Der hat da auch mal ein bisschen kritisiert, dass der Kader noch nicht so richtig wettbewerbsfähig ist. Dann kam am Deadline-Day, glaube ich, noch ein Carlos Soler und eben Jan-Kyl Herrera aus Girona. Also, das wird schon, glaube ich, noch. Aber wer auf die Tabelle schaut, wird sich wundern, was ist da passiert. Vieles passiert, wie gesagt, es ist Ubi Mendyweg, der Trainer, weg jahrelang. Von dem her, da spürt man noch so ein bisschen diese Folgen dadurch.
Dann sind wir mal gespannt, ob sich Lareal noch fängt. Uli, wenn wir auf die Premier League noch ein letztes Mal blicken, ich weiß nicht, ob du ein drittes Thema noch mit dabei hast. Ansonsten habe ich auch einen Vorschlag.
Ja, schlag was vor. Mir fällt schon noch was ein, aber schlag gern was vor. Chelsea wäre lustig, oder?
Hau ab, ey. Wenn man auf die Tabelle blickt, dann fällt einem in den Top 6 vor allem ein Team auf. Also über Bournemouth haben wir schon oft genug gesprochen und das angedeutet. Aber Sunderland auf 5. Ich will mehr wissen.
Oh ja, da willst du sehr gerne zu Recht Dinge wissen. Das ist das für mich interessanteste Team im Moment, weil ich überhaupt nicht wusste, was ich aus denen machen würde in der Saison. Es gibt ja immer einen Aufsteiger, der einfach wahllos ein Kader zusammenstellt. Sunderland schien auch so ein Team zu sein, wo ich gedacht habe, entweder das wird voll funktionieren oder es geht halt komplett in die Hose, weil du deinen Aufsteigspirit sozusagen komplett weg gibst. Aber die haben, also Abib Deraa ist schon mal ganz kurz gefallen. Das ist einer von 2, die es mir totaler angetan haben. Noah Sardikis ist der andere. Die haben so 6er, 8er Hybridin. Das ist Wahnsinn. Das macht einfach nur großen, großen Spaß. Und auch ansonsten sind die einfach sehr, sehr gut gecoacht. Haben von Regis Le Bris eine ziemlich direkte Art und Weise an die Hand gekommen, das gefällt mir gut. Mit Xhaka, wie so in der Basis der Triangeln 433. Und dann haben sie jeweils so 2 ganz breite Dreiecke. Und dann gibt es noch jemanden dazu, wie zum Beispiel Chris Rigg ist hochinteressant. Und Talbi, der dann auch neu gekommen ist, der dann auf dem Außen steht, auch so einer. Und so kommen die relativ gut. Defensive spielen sie übrigens Mann gegen Mann, was auch Harakiri auf der einen Seite sein kann. Aber sie lösen es sehr, sehr gut. Und haben einfach die Nutzen, ihre Körperlichkeit. Und das ist was, was mir bei Thunderland bis dato sehr gut gefällt. Also scheint für mich fast der Aufsteiger zu sein, der die höchsten Chancen hat, drin zu bleiben. So ganz hundertprozentig bin ich mir bei den anderen noch nicht sicher. Burnley ist mal so, mal so. Aber die sind wahrscheinlich weg, würde ich sagen. Die sind einfach zu schwach individuell. Da fokussiert sich vieles auf Jaden Anthony. Und bei Thunderland sind es gleich vier, fünf Leute, die mir echt gut gefallen. Enzo Lefe, wenn er spielt, ist wie so ein kleiner Magier fast. Und auch ansonsten haben sie mit Anildo zum Beispiel einen Außenverteidiger noch geholt, der es schon sehr gut macht. Der Torhüter, den wird Daniel noch ganz gut kennen, den Ruf, den sie verpflichtet haben. Also keine Ahnung, warum da sonst niemand draufgesprungen ist. Der sieht sehr gut aus, muss ich echt sagen. Von daher, Sunderland, die geben so ein bisschen den Looten-Ipswitch-Spot der letzten Jahre ab von einem Aufsteiger, von dem man denkt, ja, das sieht gut aus. Jetzt hoffe ich, dass sie es beibehalten und nicht einknicken und nur noch kompakt spielen irgendwann. Weil sonst, glaube ich, geht es so wieder flöten. Sondern das muss weiterhin so sein, das ist ja aggressiv. Das ist eine Pressing-Liga und wenn du nicht presst, wirst du bestraft in England. Das ist einfach so. Und wenn sie das aber beibehalten, dann– also ich habe das in unserem Podcast auch schon so gesagt– ich rang 17, 16, traue ich ihnen echt zu.
Vielleicht noch irgendwann Tore schießen. Sieben Tore nach sechs Spielen, das sind ein paar mehr, wenn es schön ist.
Ja, das stimmt, zumal die auch zumeist in den einzelnen Spielen gefallen sind. Das war auch schon letztes Jahr aber so ein leichtes Thema, dass sie da nicht in der Champions League so hundertprozentig zu den Dingen gekommen sind. Die haben keinen so hundertprozentigen Goalscorer drin. Das stimmt. Aber irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl, die machen auch noch mal was im Winter. Die haben da großen Spaß dran gefunden.
Ey, und mit Granit Xhaka an der Triangel, was soll schiefgehen? Was für ein wunderschönes Bild.
Ja, das ist ja auch eine der most random Transfers, die es gibt. Hängt auch wohl ein bisschen mit Eric den Haag zusammen. Der könnte dann bald wieder über Ajax übernehmen vielleicht. Also, das habe ich irgendwie nicht ganz verstanden, nachdem er ja ins Rheinland eigentlich zurück wollte, aus persönlichen Gründen, wie man das damals verstanden hat, glaube ich, Richtung Leverkusen. Er hätte auch Glattbacher nochmal gemacht oder irgendwas anderes. Und dann, also, ja gut, von dort aus in den Nordosten Englands. Ja, okay, warum nicht?
Vielleicht hat er die Doku gesehen. Kann ja sein. Also, Sunderland haben wir damit auch noch abgehandelt. Jakob, wir schauen nochmal kurz auf die Ligue 1 und auf ein allgemeines Thema. Die Karten, sie sprudeln nur so in der Ligue 1. Was ist da los?
Ja, es gibt sehr viele Platzverweise und vor allem ständig glatt rot. Also es gab jetzt nach sechs Spieltagen schon 18 Platzverweise in der Ligue 1. 15 Mal glatt rot, dreimal gelb rot. Das macht 0,33 Platzverweise pro Spiel. Also es ist wirklich beeindruckend. Man liegt damit europaweit, also unter den Top 5 liegen weit vorne. Man muss dazu sagen, die Ligue 1 ist da traditionell recht weit vorne auch immer. Aber in dieser Saison wird das wirklich so ein bisschen auf die Spitze getrieben. Es haben nur fünf Teams noch gar keinen Platzverweis kassiert, einige auch schon mehrere. Und es gab auch so ein paar besonders bemerkenswerte Platzverweise. Es gab zum einen jetzt am letzten Wochenende bei Startrennen gegen RC. Lons, gab es direkt nach 54 Sekunden, müsste es gewesen sein, eine glattrote Karte für Lons Jonathan Grandy, der da auch für eine Notbremse vom Platz gestellt wurde. Lons hat es tatsächlich geschafft, das Spiel noch 0 zu 0 dann auch über die 90 Minuten zu bringen, also hat sich da wacker geschlagen in Unterzahl. Und Startrennen hat irgendwie bei den spektakulären Spielen immer so ein bisschen die Finger im Spiel. Da gab es nämlich auch schon am zweiten Spieltag ein Spiel, wo Startrennen nach 11 Minuten schon zu neun nur noch war, weil sie zweimal glattrot gesehen haben. Da ist erst mir die Kamera für ein hohes Bein im Mittelfeld bei seinem Debüt für Startrennen, nach fünf Minuten schon vom Platz geflogen. Und dann gab es nach zehn Minuten und vier Sekunden noch mal glattrot für Christopher Wu, der da auch eine Notbremse noch gezogen hat. Und Startrennen hatte auch am ersten Spieltag schon eine glattrote Karte gesehen, für auch ein recht hartes VL-Spiel. Also da hatten sie dann drei rote Karten in den ersten beiden Spielen. Das Spiel haben sie dann auch verloren, 4 zu 0 gegen Lorient. Und dass es tatsächlich auch war, dass der schnellste Doppelplatz verweist, den es in der Liga, zumindest seit Obta aus der Saison 92, 93, die Daten erfasst gab. Davor war der Rekord von Bastia auch gegen Startrennen, allerdings damals für Bastia. Und es waren noch zwei gelb-rote Karten innerhalb von 16 Minuten. Tatsächlich war auch die rote Karte nach 54 Sekunden nicht die schnellste. Es gab vor ein paar Jahren mal eine rote Karte für Jean-Claire Tudibau, als er noch bei Lidzawa war. Das dürften nur so 12 oder 13 Sekunden gewesen sein, also eigentlich direkt vom Anpfiff weg. Und ja, auch europaweit sucht das so ein bisschen seinesgleichen, diese schnelle Doppelrote Karte. Ich habe mal geguckt, es gab das in der Serie A 2005, mal im Februar, auch nach elf Minuten zwei rote Karten für die Fiorentina bei Sampdoria. Wir haben ja jetzt keinen aus der Serie A dabei, aber sicherlich auch bemerkenswert. Und ja, es ist echt krass, wie viele Spieler in der Liga jetzt vor immer vorzeitig den Platz verlassen mussten in dieser Saison.
Also da können wir sehr gespannt sein, ob das so weitergeht oder ob sich das irgendwann noch einpendelt auf dem für die Liga normalen Niveau. Aber auf jeden Fall bemerkenswert und haben ja vielleicht auch manche Hörerinnen und Hörer schon mal so am Rande mitbekommen. Also gerade dieser Platzverweis nach 54 Sekunden. Das war ja durchaus auch Thema. Daniel, wir blicken noch ein letztes Mal.
Ich habe noch kurz was dazu zu sagen. Es gibt natürlich auch wieder aus der Liga Kritik an den Schiedsrichtern.
Ja, die Jury sind schon, sehe ich auch so. Klar.
Viele Trainer beklagen sich, dass die roten Karten zu hart sind. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, bei einigen Notbremsen ist auch so ein bisschen die Frage, ob das wirklich eine Notbremse ist, weil da dann oft noch Spieler so nebenbei auch waren, wo man sich fragt, hätten die nicht noch eingreifen können. Und ansonsten sind aber auch viele rote Karten wirklich vermeidbar, würde ich mal behaupten.
Ja, ansonsten einfach Schiedsrichtertausch mit La Liga und dann wird das mit dem Niveau alles passen.
Ich bin ja auch aller Ligen immer sehr zufrieden mit den Schiedsrichter.
Genau, also generell. In der Bundesliga habe ich jetzt keine Diskussion mitbekommen über irgendwelche Schiedsrichter an den letzten Spieltagen. Nun ja, schauen wir nochmal in die Niederlande. Daniel, da habe ich den Eindruck, dass vorhin mit Rüben von Bommel vielleicht schon einer derjenigen genannt worden sein könnte, über die du jetzt kurz sprechen willst.
So ist es, denn was wirklich auffällt in der letzten Zeitperiode, dass sehr, sehr viele Söhne mit berühmten Namen jetzt in den Jugendmannschaften spielen. Und nicht nur in den Jugendmannschaften, auch teilt schon in den Profi-Afteilungen. Zum Beispiel eben Rüben von Bommel, der Sohn von Marc von Bommel, der ist jetzt für, ich glaube, 15 Millionen von AZ zu Fays Way gekommen, ist Flügelspieler und ist eigentlich, war schon auf dem besten Weg, seine Luftmarken zu unterlassen. Sechs Spieler, schon drei Tore erzielt. Auch in der Rebensliga schon ein Tor gemacht für Fays Way. Und dann kam eben die schon erwähnte blöde Knieverletzung, die ihn wirklich bis kommendes Jahr wohl außer Gefecht setzt. Das ist echt tragisch. Aber wenn man in der Liga schaut, hat man auch im aktuellen Profi-Bereich, zum Beispiel bei Telstar, hat man den Sohn von Ronald Koeman, der da heißt Ronald Koeman Junior. Und der steht im Tor bei Telstar und macht die Sache auch sehr solide. Oder zum Beispiel Sidney van Houdonck, der war auch, glaube ich, mal in Bologna, in Italien, ist jetzt bei Breda, spielt mit Hoepie zusammen. Und der hat ja auch einen bekannten Vater, Pierre van Houdonck, der war bei Feyernoord. Und wenn man sich in die Jugendabteilung anguckt, wir haben einen Leim, Liam van Nistelrooy, der Mittelstürmer ist. Wir haben einen Sepp Hüntelaar, auch bei PSV, der ist 16, ist auch Mittelstürmer. Wir haben bei Feyernoord in der Jugend den Sohn von Robin van Persie. Wir haben bei Milan, auch international, haben wir den Sohn von Clement Seedorf, der ist 18. Wir haben bei Ajax Demian van der Vaart, der ist 19. Wir haben Wissi Sneijder, der ist 19, bei Utrecht. Wir haben einen Kläuferd bei Barca, der ist 18. Die sind alle in dieser Generation, die sind alle 16 bis 18 Jahre. Und die sind auch alle relativ sanitär, das man so hört. Das heißt, die spielen auch teilweise auch niederländische Bundeskommandmannschaft. Schon. Das heißt, in so 3, 4 Jahren werde ich mal sehr gespannt, welche bekannten Namen wir alle im Team haben. Wir könnten die ganze Generation quasi wiederholen. Also, das ist mir aufgefallen. Und gerade auch jetzt, weil zum Beispiel so ein Leim von Nistelreus und PSV, der ist diese Saison jetzt in die Nachwuchsabteilung gewechselt zu PSV. Und die sind auch alle sehr nah dran am Rufebereich, wenn es die Älteren von denen. Und insofern könnte Rüben van Mummel quasi ein Vorbild sein für viele andere junge Spieler. Das ist ja mal ein bisschen die Frage, ist der Name dann Segen oder Fluch oder Segen? Jetzt ist es zu großer Druck, was noch medial oftmals dann generiert wird. Bislang scheint das noch nicht so der Fall zu sein, was aber auch damit zu tun hat, dass sie eben noch sehr junge sind und eben noch nicht in die Poko stehen. Spannend wird es dann, wenn sie wirklich dann mal in den Rufebereich kommen. Bei van Mummel hat man jetzt nicht das Gefühl, dass das ein großes Ding für ihn ist. Wie es dann bei allen anderen, die es ja wirklich zuhauf gibt, so aussehen wird, das lässt sich natürlich erst in ein paar Jahren sagen. Aber da könnte man auf jeden Fall ein Auge drauf haben, auf wie sie bekannten waren.
Absolut fantastisch. Also das niederländische Nationalteam könnte aussehen, wie ich es in PS5 gespielt habe, glaube ich. Das ist ja wirklich großartig.
Sie sind leider nur sehr oft im Offensivbereich. Also die würden sich dann gegenseitig Kürze wegnehmen. Also es ist positionell unausgewogen.
Hat Edwin van der Saar etwa nur Töchter oder was da los?
Das ist mir ja riesenbekannt, aber das wird sich auf wenigstens auch mal rausfinden.
Was heißt denn da nur Töchter? Das niederländische Frauen-Nationalteam ist, würde ich mal sagen, erfolgreicher als das der Männer.
Der junge Werdergolf Hesseling ist auch schon da.
Ja, ist schon da. Der müsste bei Twente spielen.
Ach, ganz fantastisch. Also das war ein sehr schönes letztes Thema. Da haben wir auf jeden Fall einen Blick drauf. Ihr vier. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Vielen Dank an Jakob Haffke, Daniel Zander, Uli Hebel und an Nils Kern, den wir übrigens vielleicht doch gesehen haben. Ich habe hier noch so– ja, ja, ja, ja, ja. Ich habe gesehen, hier gibt es jetzt zwei Nilse auf einmal in der Aufnahme. Aber die wirklich sehen wir erst, wenn das Licht angeht, wenn die Dateien hochgeladen sind. Deswegen mal sehen. Ihr wisst es schon.
Bei Tiki-Taka hört man mich auch nicht. Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Jetzt sieht man mich nicht mehr.
Immer diese Insider. Aber damit haben wir ja auch schon elegant darauf hingewiesen. Ihr könnt sehr gerne in den Show Notes mal gucken, wo man die vier sonst noch so lesen und eben auch hören kann. Denn ich weiß ja, die Ligatour kommt manchen von euch nicht oft genug, aber es gibt ja genügend andere Podcasts, in denen ja genau auch Leute wie hier auch noch zu hören sind. Also schaut einfach mal in die Show Notes oder in die Videobeschreibung. Ich danke euch vier und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, denn diese Sendung hier ist von euch allein finanziert. Wir sind und bleiben Paywall-Werbe- und Sponsoren-frei, finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung auf rasenfunk.de, da erfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Und natürlich auch eine Videobeschreibung und den Show Notes. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Joris, bei Sebastian, bei Ran, Milo, Ran, bei Schützi und bei Holli90. Herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Ansonsten empfehlt uns sehr gerne weiter, abonniert die anderen Formate des Rasenfunks. Hier geht es dann weiter am Sonntag mit einer Folge zur 2. Liga der Männer. Ansonsten wisst ihr ja, es gibt ein großes Programm beim Rasenfunk. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bleibt oder werdet gesund und bis bald wieder. Macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen.
Vielen Dank.